vsauce kevin here with a game you can't
possibly
comprehend really it's too hard for you
your brain can't take it look
i'll show you
that's it are you sweating yet you
should be
all right as you stare into these dots
your brain starts to short circuit
doesn't it no why would it
i mean it's just two dots i could draw
out
all the possible moves for a game this
simple
look i'll show you
[Music]
okay my award-winning handwriting aside
this was a lot more complicated
than i thought it was gonna be and the
thing is as it scales
analyzing what appears to be the
simplest game
in the world doesn't just break your
brain
computers can't even crunch the
possibilities
here's how it works the game of sprout
starts with
any number of dots placed anywhere the
boundaries of the game board
are limitless so put the dots wherever
you want we'll play with
two dots but you can't just play with
yourself
you need an opponent yes yes
a worthy adversary you need
let's go over the three rules of sprouts
first a player draws a line from one dot
to another
or from one dot back to itself lines can
be curved or they can be straight
they just can't cross another line or
themselves
when you draw a line you get to place a
new dot anywhere on that new line
and in sprouts no dot can have more than
three lines coming from it or going to
it
once a dot has three lines it's an
unplayable
dead dot the winner of sprouse is the
last person to draw a line
or to put it another way the player who
can't draw another line
loses okay now my friend and i will play
a
two dot game of sprouts go first i will
all right yoda dude okay hang on all
right fine
just go right all right great job you
gotta make sure you draw a new dot
on the line yes yes yes
invented this game i did sprouts trained
many jedi minds
hundreds of years hundreds of years
sprouts was created in 1967 by cambridge
mathematicians john conway and michael
martin alternators
dots lead to lines lines lead to dots
sprouts is the path to the light side of
the and i just won
alive this dot still is
yeah yeah but you can't connect it to
anything look dead
dead dead dead and you can't draw a line
to get to this one
[Music]
explain why i lost
you must
all right the first player can always
lose a two-dot game against a perfect
opponent because
even though it's complex your brain can
analyze
two dot sprouts i mean you could
literally just memorize this whole
game tree chart to make exactly the
right move as player 2
rendering player 1 helpless player 2 can
engineer the 2 dot game so that it ends
on a 4th move win for them
but conway and patterson figured out
when the game
has to end check it out they discovered
that a game of sprouts
must be completed by three n minus one
moves
where n equals the number of starting
dots so that means
a two dot game is concluded in no more
than
five moves because three times two minus
one
equals five so problem solved right
no why because the game can play out in
so many different ways what's
interesting is that player 1
actually has 11 ways of winning compared
to player 2 having only
6 it's just that if player 2 knows
exactly what they're doing they can
always facilitate
one of their six winning outcomes
what's amazing to me about sprouts is
this is all
just with two dots as soon as we add a
third dot to the game become more
difficult to analyze than tic-tac-toe it
does
adding a third dot at the beginning
means that we could have up to eight
moves to determine a winner
since three times three minus one equals
8.
but we have more possible moves to start
it isn't hard to figure out how many
possibilities we begin with
it's just n times n plus 1 over 2.
so here we have our number of dots at
start and number of initial possible
moves
n times n plus one over two and number
of moves to determine
a winner that's three n minus one so if
you have two dots to start the game
the initial possible moves would be
three with three dots to start that
jumps to
six for four it's ten for five it's
fifteen
and so on now that we know
this what's the guaranteed strategy for
winning
every time there isn't one because since
the game can develop in
so many different ways especially once
you start playing with
four or five dots players will have to
constantly re-analyze
and adapt their moves to force their
opponent
into a loss you need to factor in which
dots are still live and
which ones are dead you need to force
your opponent into bad
moves and eventually no moves at all
there's just no formula for this
adapt and overcome you must
what we do know kind of is who can win
the first real glimpse into dominant
sproutology came
from dennis mollison a professor of
applied probability
at harriet watt university conway bet
mollison
10 shillings before the 1971
decimalization of the british monetary
system
and equivalent to a little under 10
bucks today that he couldn't complete
a full analysis of a six sprout
game within a month well he did
and it only took 47 pages
i'm not looking forward to picking those
up mollison's analysis
led to the conclusion that sprouts games
with zero
one or two dots could always be won by
the second player
games with three four and five dots
could always be won by the first player
the second player can always win with
six dots but
that's where the computational power of
the human mind started to strain under
the weight
of the sprout there were just too many
scenarios
to compute wait how can you have a game
with zero
dots well if there are zero dots the
first player wouldn't be able to
draw a line so the second player
wins one thing that's really weird
about sprouts is you'd think that
playing the game would visually
result in nothing but near random lines
and
patterns but conway and mollison
unearthed
something bugs they call this
photosem the fundamental theorem of
zeroth order
morabundity which states that any
sprouts game of
n dots must last at least two and moves
and
if it lasts exactly 2n moves
the final board will consist of one of
five
insect patterns laos beetle
cockroach earwig and scorpion surrounded
by
any number of lice scorpions are
arachnids not insects but
these guys don't have no time for no
biology and that's
fatasm for you but this was all 50 years
ago
how has sproutology progressed since
well it lay dormant for decades until
carnegie mellon university fired up its
computers in 1990.
using some of the most advanced
processors of the
era computer scientists david applegate
guy jacobson and daniel slater were able
to map
sprouts conclusively up to 11 dots
they found the same pattern 6 7 and 8
favored the second player
9 10 and 11 favored the first player
there appears to be an endless
three loss three win pattern with a
cycle length
of six dots in 2001
ficardi and luccio published a new
analysis technique for the sprouts game
that showed a simpler proof
of sprouts to seven dots by hand
now we're up to eleven so we're making
progress on the
pencil and paper front but what about
1 272 dots or
a billion dots were not even close
like really not close
julianne lamont and simone vienno
created a computer program
called glop that could calculate
sprout's results more efficiently
and in 2011 they were only able to
process up to
44 dots consecutively their results were
in line with carnegie mellon's cycle of
6 but the
computational power and time required to
get us to proving results with say
a million dots is way beyond our reach
it's been over half a century since
conway and patterson were drinking tea
in the cambridge math department's
common room and
playing around with inventing a simple
pencil and paper-based game
they noticed that the game was spreading
throughout the department and then
the campus seeing students hunched over
tables and
spotting the discarded remnants of epic
sprouts battles they stumbled on
something
so big and so complex that the human
mind can't fully
fathom it beyond a very
limited point and it all started by just
connecting a couple of dots
and as always thanks for watching